[Music]
the world could always use more heroes
here we are we talked about our top 24
games we've gone in depth with five four
three two here we are number one
it is overwatch
there are a lot of great shooters this
year and a lot of fantastic shooters
this year overwatch
top that lists it top our favorite games
list
Eric Tate you played a lot of overwatch
and I think the first most alluring
aspect of this game is its heroes this
iconic cast of people who have already
become these cultural icons do you tell
me about them and what makes them push
this game forward yeah I mean just a
wonderful cast it's it's got a big
diversity from you know offensive heroes
defensive heroes to support heroes and I
think that's part of the reason why this
game is so so fun for us you know you
could pick your soldier 76 who's kind of
like a cod player you can pick your fare
who's kind of like your quake player or
now with Sombra she's kind of like the
spy from TF and so you have this huge
diverse cast that lets you play in very
different ways and you might master one
character but you might learn another
character just to fill roles and roles
are so important and it's just beautiful
the beautiful thing
yeah you touched on a little bit but
that's one of my favorite things about
this game you know I go into it one day
and I'm just telling a lot of people as
you know Reaper or Sombra but another
game I go into it and I'm mercy I'm
healing my teammates or I'm onna one of
my favorite characters and I'm healing
it from afar while also hurting other
teams you don't have to be killing
people to contribute to this game which
is kind of special for a shooter Mary
what was your experience like learning
different characters and kind of figure
out how you could contribute
yeah overwatch really gets to pull from
a wider range of people who want to play
games like this because this isn't just
a shooter this is an objective based
team game and you can help your team not
just by killing people if you're really
into mobility you should pick someone
like illusio or maybe a mercy where
you're just kind of soaring around the
map or moving really quickly healing
people into helping or perhaps maybe you
just want to help your team stay safe
and and carry the the payload forward
well then you're a Reinhard there's so
many other ways one of my favorite
characters is Mae who's just constantly
changing the map or or messing with the
opposing team and what they're trying to
accomplish
it's brilliant how you can utilize these
characters in various ways and sometimes
not in the ways you might expect and
that's something that this game does and
I haven't seen in games in a really long
time
yeah the more you learn the characters
the more you figure out different
nuances you can kind of take advantage
of with their abilities and their powers
and whatnot that's not even to mention
the map design which Blizzard despite
the fact that this is their first
shooter pretty much hone to a craft it's
just almost artistic and how they vary
the verticality 'z the different sight
lines you know how this choke point
becomes just crazy for these firefights
Aaron you know like these maps are
burned into our mind by this point even
the new ones that we've almost got to
learn like Antarctica a3 b3 these maps
facilitate these heroes clashing in
these crazy colorful like neon laser
blasted ways like tell me about these
maps what makes them so good it's really
what you said they're just like another
balanced on top of a balance it's it's
amazing to think that different
characters all work on these same maps
but they they totally change how you
play right like you have a Genji or
Hanzo you're trying to get up to a high
point where you know you can snipe
someone or get to the back lines or
you're lucio and your wall riding a well
or wall riding inside of the building
healing your teammates while the
opposing teams like where the hell is
this like healing coming from or your
road Hawk trying to hook someone into a
well and it's just all these
environmental things are so amazing to
see and it's it just won't go with the
word brilliant
they found a way to just crap these maps
and make them so balanced with the
characters yeah it's crazy that
everything you just said is like second
nature to me that doesn't sound crazy
but you know back in the game release we
still had so much to learn and we are
still learning right there's that crazy
fun of mastering a character like I
prefer sorry our on or McCree I love
those characters I will stand by them
but it's just as fun to learn someone
I'm not familiar with like a zenyatta or
a Sabra that balance between those two
poles is kind of what keeps me going and
overwatch and finding the new nuances
Mary do you find that happening often as
well yeah the game brings that out in
you because it's allowing players to
change characters mid-match it wants you
to do that it wants you to feed off of
the connection you have with your
teammates that the characters that
they've chosen the map and then your
opposing team and how all those dynamics
come together in these tremendous
moments of success in failure they're
eating these times where you're
completely out of time and you're trying
to get a payload to the next objective
and you're like you're pretty much done
but if you can get Sariah to use that
graviton all at the right time and then
use like a Hanzo old to kind of finish
off the opposing team you get a team
wipe and you will just feel it everyone
gets excited when you have these moments
of glory and you can have them in a
million different ways because of all
the different ways these pieces come
together it's just really cool how
they've brought these moments out in us
you won't win them all but when you do
what you do get play the game you feel
amazing yeah I mean overwatch is
ambitious to say the very least the fact
that blizzards kind of borrowing from
the entire shooter genre since back in
like the late 80s almost til today with
it you know like influencing from
titanfall quake doom Wolfenstein all
these different shooters the fact that
it coalesces into this one
genius kind of game and how it all feels
balance how it all feels exhilarating
even this many months after release it's
hard as hell to set yourself apart from
all the other fantastic shooters in 2016
it's even harder to become the one game
that we cannot stop going back to and
that is why it is GameSpot's number one
game of 2016